PHONE IN OR ORDER ONLINE AT
CHILE CHILE'S DOT COM WELCOME
BACK TO LAS VEGAS. NOW THE
FINAL DAYS OF SUMMER ARE UPON
US AND LABOR DAY WEEKEND IS
AROUND THE CORNER, BUT IT'S
NOT TOO LATE TO PLAN SOME LAST
MINUTE TRAVEL ACCORDING TO
TRAVEL EXPERT JANINE TURNER
TORE WELCOME BACK.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE GREAT TO
SEE YOU AGAIN ARE YOU SEEING A
LOT OF PEOPLE SCRAMBLING
TRYING TO MAKE TRAVEL PLANS
RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, I H,THINK I'M IN THIS
SUMMER OF A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
AIRPORT AND HIGH PRICES PEOPLE
ARE STILL LOOKING TO GET AWAY
BECAUSE THEY MAYBE DIDN'T TAKE
THAT TRIP EARLIER THIS SUMMER
YOU KNYOOW YOLOOKING AHEAD AHTO
LABOR DAY WEY EKEND THAT LAST
LONG WEEKEND OF SUMMER AND  I
DID FIND SOME DEALS OUT THERE
THAT I THINK PEOPLE BE HAPPY
TO MORE THAN HAPPY TO SEE
INCLUDING MYSELF SO LET'S GET
TO A RE TAKING US. WELL OF THE
E FIRSE T THE INGSE  E E E I WO
CLOSER TO TALKING ABOUT T LATT
THIS DESTINATION IN LATE
SUMMER BECAUSE IT'S JUST A
BEAUTIFUL TIME METO GET STILL
HIT THE TRAILS GET OUT ON THE
WATER AND YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
YOU KNOW YOU COULD ACTUALLY LYLY
DRIVE THERE. 7 HOUR DRIVE SO A
LITTLE BIT ON THE L TONGE TR  T
PROPERTIES THERE THIS  IS
KIND  OF PLACE WHERE I DON'T
MIND SPLURGING A LITTLE BIT IT
ITPLITACESIT LIKITE THITE RIITT
LAKE TAHOE, WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY STUNNING LAKE A
REALLY NICE AND THIS LATE
SUMMER WITH ALL THE WILD
FLOWERS BLOOMING BEFORE THE
SNOW STARTS TO COME IN JUST A
MONTH OR SPEAKING OF THE
SEASON'S NEXT YOU HAVE A NEW
YORK WHAT'S GOING ON THERE.
NEW YORK AGAIN A GREAT TIME TO
VISIT YOU KNOW, I LOVE NEW
YORK IN AUGUST AND ESPECIALLY
LATE AUGUST AND LABOR DAY
WEEKEND BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
LOCALS HEAD TO THE SHORE SO
YOU HAVE A LOT OF CITY TO
YOURSELF THAT MEANS WE'RE
GOING TO FIND GRINEAT DEALS ON
AIRFARE FROM VEGAS TO NEW YORK
OVER LABOR DAY WEEKEND FROM
$200 SO REALLY AFFORDABLE
COMPARED TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN A
SUMMER LOT OF AVAILABILITY TY
GREAT CLASSIC HOTELS PLACES
LIKE THE WAS JUST PART ACTION
RIGHT IN THE HEART OF THE CITY
WHILE $200 TO GO TO NEW YORK
YES, I'M IN AND NEXT WE HAVE
PORTLAND AND SAN FRANCISCO.
ANOTHER FAVOR EASY TO GET ON
THE  WEST  COAST. DO LIKE THE
SHORT FLIGHTS AS WELL BECAUSE
YOU CAN GET THERE QUICK AND
NOT TO WORRY ABOUT A LOT OF
ISSUES YOU DO GOING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WERE LINED UP AGAIN AI
AIJUAIST AIA BEAIAUTIAIFUL PLAC
VISIT IN LATE SUMMER, I LOVE
IT BECITAUSEIT THITEY ITHAVE TH
STUDENT TRUCKS. THEY'RE
BEAUTIFUL JAPANESE GARDEN TO
GET OUGETSIDGEE THGEE CITY THER
MUCH BEAUTIFUL HIKING NGNGNGNGN
MOUNTAINS RIGHT AIRFARE OVER
LABOR DABOY WEEKEND FROM VEGAS
FROM $160 SO EVEN BETTER TO
GET TO PORTLAND. LALABEAUTIFUL
I THINK I'M SEEING A PICTURE
OF THE BAY  BAREA B NOW  BSAN B
BFR BANCISCO RIGHT.
TO INCLUDE THIS ONE BECAUSE
HAVE LEEWAY OUT OVER THIS
HOLIDAY WEEKEND FROM $47 ROUND
FROM VEGAS TOAS SAN FRANCISCO
OVER LABOR DAY WEEKEND LEAVING
ON FRIDAY COMING BACK ON
TUESDAY YOESU CANNOT REALLY DO
ANY BETTER THAN THAT. BUT
THERE'S THAT'S WHE'SRE THE SAME
ON THE AIR FARE AND D THEN YOU
STATES GREAT PROPERTIES PLACES
LIKE THE W SAN N FRANCISCO RIGH
IN THE HEART OF THE CITY I
LOVE SAN FRANCISCO THAT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE EVERYTHING
RIGHT IN THE BAY AREA. BUT YOU
ALSO HAVE PLACES LIKE NEAR
WOODS AND SONOMA RIGHT OUTSIDE
WE WERE GETTING INTO HARVEST
SEASON WITH THESE WINE COUNTRY
AREAS AND JUST ONE OF OW LET'ST
TIMES OF YEAR TO VISIT THANK
YOU SO MUCH I'VE LIVED IN THE
BAY. SO I KNOW VERY WELL, IT'S